I'm not really a big fan of John
luchador anymore.
I think.
I'm not trying to be disrespectful.
I just think I've outgrown him because I
was so influential to me that the
beginning of my aesthetic,
it's a director of like wanting to be a
director.
He's kind of like lack of complete any
type of film style.
Just this wanting to make movies for
love of it is the one who taught me the
fun and the freedom and the joy of of
breaking rules just fucking around with
the entire medium.
Like many other things in our modern
world.
The course of film history was changed
forever by the Second World War that
despite having grown out of him,
Quentin Tarantino's self-conscious
postmodern aesthetic is a direct
descendant of the self conscious
postmodern work of John Luca Dart and
the French new wave of which Godard is a
pioneer,
emerges and is a response to the
circumstances arising out of the end of
World War Two.
Let me explain.
A year after the end of the war,
after the liberation of France from Nazi
control,
French Prime Minister Leon blue traveled
to Washington DC to meet with Secretary
of state,
James Burns can negotiate an agreement
that would cancel Francis $2,000,000,000
ward.
They're the result of the bloom burns
agreement was the almost complete
opening of French markets to American
cultural products,
particularly films before this
agreement,
France had imposed quotas on the number
of American films allowed to play in
French theaters as a way to preserve the
unique identity of French cinema.
The Bloomberg's agreement decimated
those quarters,
resulting in the free market domination
of American Hollywood movies in France
into this universe.
The founding members of the French new
wave grew up in the pages of Du Cinema.
They advanced a new form of film theory
criticizing many of their French
forefathers and praising the work of
Hollywood studio directors like Alfred
Hitchcock,
Orson Welles and John finished that job
awash in hundreds of Hollywood movies
and in depth analysis of American art
tourers Gianluca Dart makes breathless
from a story treatment by new wave
compatriots,
Francois Truffaut and Claude chabrol.
Breathless is an extended investigation
of a French filmmaker identity in the
shadow of Hollywood dominance of indeed
whether an identity informed by another
nation's culture can exist at all.
Breathless tells the story of small time
Crook,
Michelle in the aftermath of his murder
of a police officer on his way to see
his American lover,
Patricia in Paris.
Michel models his personality on
Humphrey Bogart just as the film models
itself on the Hollywood crime thriller,
but in both cases,
these identifications are continually
frustrated.
For example,
take a look at the films inciting
incident.
The film opens with Michelle dressed
like a parody of an American gangster
mimicking a gesture attributed to folk
art.
He then steals and American oldsmobile
from an American military officer,
which almost immediately furnishes him
with an implement to make his identity
complete.
A revolver.
After running a light,
Michelle is chased by two motorcycle
cops.
One eventually tracks him down and a
shootout and sues the classic dramatic
moment of the film,
the war,
but look at the sequence of shots in
which this shootout I'm full.
The whole scene plays like a misfire of
these kinds of moments.
Not only does a murderer seemed totally
unmotivated for the crime committed,
but we don't even get to see the cops
face.
The shootout takes place over only five
shots in 10 seconds with imagery and
sound effects out of sync,
and the camera impulsively favors
extreme closeups that obscure the action
instead of wide shots that would have
made everything clear.
Everything in the sequence serves to rob
me,
shell of his part in the confrontation.
The film itself intervenes to strip the
scene down to bare formulaic elements.
In this way,
the film is always watching over
Michelle,
making comments on his immature desire
to become bogart or actually
interjecting itself to upset that
desire.
Later,
Michelle confronts a poster of his hero,
a giant image of Bogart from his very
last movie.
The harder they fall,
you can see Michelle's Pale reflection
being dwarfed by his hero,
and then you have a face off between the
two men,
both totally stone faced and unreadable
seconds later,
the film loudly announces itself by
ending the scene with a wacky,
awkward,
outmoded Iris.
What's being called to attention here?
Well,
I think the late film critic Dennis
Turner gives us a hint when he cites the
French psychoanalyst,
Jacques Lacan seat,
Louis Kahn's.
Most famous contribution to our
understanding of human development is
something called the mirror stage.
It describes the moment when a baby
first sees itself in the mirror is that
little girl,
you too young to have any control yet
over itself.
The infant recognizes a unity in its
mirror version and aspires to that unity
projecting itself into the place of the
other.
This means that the very formation of
ourselves,
the first time we perceive ourselves as
a subject,
what we perceive is not really us.
It's an imaginary projection of us.
For this reason,
the human subjects says Lacan is always
divided.
It's never really hold.
Michelle is someone consumed by his
identification looking at bogart.
He doesn't recognize the impossibility
of his hero.
He just stares intently forward and it's
left to the film and it's anachronistic,
fade out to inform us that it knows
better.
Michelle's immaturity is matched by his
love interests,
Patricia,
that long famous scene that sits at the
heart of this movie with Michelle.
Hold up in Patricia's bedroom is
proceeded by a long look in the mirror
by Patricia and it features mirrors all
the way through and images of lovers and
other men and women.
Both characters are lost in search of a
solid identity that might be reflected
in the other.
There are back and forth is a constant
oblique,
probing into the other,
hoping to mind some reaction,
some statement that might explain
finally
who they are.
At the end of the film,
Michelle finally gets everything he
needs to escape,
but after Patricia betrays him to the
police,
his imaginary identification with Bogart
is finally broke.
The tragedy is that the film still
forces him along the tracks of the genre
inside which he's trapped.
The cops bumbling like silly parodies of
themselves all throughout the film still
nonetheless gunned him down breathless
like it's hero oscillates.
Between these two registers,
it wants to participate in the Hollywood
filmmaking it admires,
but it knows that such an identification
is impossible.
So it deals with this by being self
conscious,
by using jump cuts,
awkward transitions,
by robbing the classic moments of their
force or making the heroes bloody final
steps way longer than it could ever
possibly be forcing you outside of the
films,
text or back into it.
Again,
depending on how you look at it,
it's no surprise that the effects of war
are fast and unexpected.
America flooded France with its films,
onto which the new wave filmmakers
projected a superiority that they
created by then identifying with it in
their movies.
In other words,
American economic dominance created an
ideological dominance in the minds of
dominated for the only way to deal with
this was to be conscious of the dynamic
unfixed nature of these identities.
Indeed,
it's the only way that we can deal with
the dynamic unfixed nature of our own
identities.
The unexpected thing is how influential
that consciousness was
when it eventually came back across the
Atlantic.
Hey everybody,
buddy,
thanks for watching.
The first set of nerd writer stickers
have been sent out in the mail.
So you got some of those on Patriot and
check for that.
Also,
there are a lot more sicker than I
thought,
so I'm going to put up 60 more sets of
those stickers on my patrion page,
which you can claim by clicking right
here,
pledging $3 per video,
and you get two stickers.
You've already got the reward I'd asked
you to keep pledging just because you
know,
that's what makes this channel possible.
My patriotic,
you know,
these videos take like 50 hours to make.
So it is a full time job,
you know,
legitimately,
and I hope you guys see that reflected
in the quality of the content.
Um,
so thank you guys so much again and I
will see you all next Wednesday.